very little easy dinner living this
cauliflower nosh
I think she means nuki heck even yaki
would have been better than not
cauliflower that was Hannah G on her
Instagram over the weekend after a
little Trader Joe's run and people went
nuts on social media over her
pronunciation of the word me oke
according to the Oxford English
Dictionary it's okay okay okay okay now
that we got that straight I actually
don't think this is that big of a deal
and technically it is nosh and Hannah
doesn't think it's a big deal either she
took to Twitter to respond to this user
who wrote quote can we please discuss
the insane way this former bachelor
contestant pronounces Naoki henro quotes
have y'all ever said a word wrong before
I was like I'm not really sure if that's
something I wouldn't be involved with
also reminder Hannah G is forever
winning because her relationship with
Dylan is the cutest I mean as I'm pretty
solid
I mean I fell in love with Hannah pretty
quickly and I think it's just because
she caught me so off guard with who she
is a person and just how amazing she is
and I couldn't be happier it's the
choosing a five-four was the best
student I ever made and I'm just so
excited for the future told ya
anyways Hannah G was also too busy
supporting Hannah B to care about the
great yoki debate of 2019 Hannah be won
the People's Choice Award for
competition contestant on Sunday night
well this is weird
thank you all so much
this award means a lot to me because it
just affirms that it's okay to be
vulnerable and put your heart out there
and that people will receive and give
that love back and that's everyone who
supported and it loves me
this crazy amazing year like how is this
happening to me
and here's the real kicker she won
against two of her exes
Colton Underwood and Tyler Cameron you
know it's just a girl from Alabama but
thank you for allowing me to be that
girl from Alabama to shine my light and
yeah that's salsa but both guys were
good sports
Hannah hugged Colton after she won and
Tyler seemed super happy for her as he
watched her take the stage
we also know Tyler is rooting for Hannah
on Dancing with the Stars
so rooting her on I hope she wins that
was it the mirror ball alright guys that
is it for today for all the latest on
bachelor nation make sure that you stick
with all things et until next time I'm
Katie crafts and bye for now
[Music]